[music playing]
SIGOURNEY WEAVER
(VOICEOVER): China
has changed a lot since I first
came here in the late '70s.
What used to be sleepy villages
are now thriving mega cities.
Back then, China's most
valued asset was cheap labor,
and so they became a
factory to the world,
growing their economy 70-fold
in less than four decades.
Think about that.
Nothing like it
has happened before
in the history of mankind.
To power it all, China built
more than a thousand coal
plants which contribute
to an energy sector
that pumps out an
astounding 20% of the gases
warming the planet.
SIGOURNEY WEAVER:
I like this one.
KEVIN MO: Try it.
Nice.
That looks nice on you.
Is it me?
Yeah?
KEVIN MO: Looks nice on you.
SIGOURNEY WEAVER: Were
you born in China?
SIGOURNEY WEAVER
(VOICEOVER): Kevin Mo
is a top climate
adviser to the American
and Chinese governments.
He came down from
Beijing to meet with me.
KEVIN MO: In the Walmart,
a lot of "Made in China"
stuff, exactly like here.
That's why they are saying
this is a factory of the world.
Yeah.
And so that's what
China becomes now.
SIGOURNEY WEAVER (VOICEOVER):
He tells me if China's going
to quit coal, it
will have to pivot
away from so much
reliance on manufacturing
and dirty industry.
So how will the
economy have to adjust?
How will it change?
Well, now you
have to transition
it to a service-based
economy, which is finance.
- Finance.
- IT.
OK.
Insurance.
Those kind of things.
Yeah, got it.
It's not like energy
intensified industries,
like steel, cement,
those kinds of things.
SIGOURNEY WEAVER: Yeah, got it.
So it's different.
So if they can make
that transition--
If they can make
that transition,
the economic growth
will be more sustainable
and consume less energy,
but generate more revenues.
OK.
In your opinion, can they do it?
And can they do it as
fast as they hope to?
Well, let's say this.
If China doesn't make
all these changes
and still use the previous
growth model, economic growth
model, then the scenario
would be by 2050,
China's carbon
emissions would be
more than the current total
carbon emissions in the world.
Oh my goodness.
SIGOURNEY WEAVER
(VOICEOVER): That much carbon
dioxide in the air would make
life on earth unbearable.
But Kevin claims China's
leaders acknowledge this threat,
and are making plans to
ensure that doesn't happen.
The problem is that if China
shifts away from manufacturing,
other countries-- including
ones that burn lots of coal--
will be picking up the
slack, and so the benefit
to the climate is unclear.